every second of every day countries
fiercely compete on everything from
muscles to scientific research a tiny
economic fluctuation or single word
change in regulation is enough to
determine who does business where and
ultimately the power of nations but
while all of this is happening countries
turn around to give away billions of
dollars in foreign aid money that could
have grown its economy or strengthened
its military so why do countries give
aid and how can we make sense of who
gives money to whom do countries have an
Alfred Nobel moment of guilt sending
reparations for their misdeeds before
quickly returning to cutthroat
competition of course not
like everything political the assumed
explanation should never be kindness or
carelessness but rational and selfish
calculation the reason aid exists
explains why it's so ineffective even in
the largest amounts and with the best
intentions
[Music]
the first thing to understand is that
foreign aid is really a trade for policy
with the benefit of appearing more like
charity sign this treaty or support this
war and your money will keep on coming
of course trade is not inherently a bad
thing if one country wants something
from another and they agree on a fair
price who cares if it's disguised as
foreign aid everyone is better off but
this kind of trade is different because
it isn't country to country but leader
to leader this is the mistake that so
many of us make if you think about
politics only in terms of countries
you'll miss the forest for the trees
politicians make deals not citizens and
their interest is first and foremost
staying in power foreign aid deals are
made when one leader wants another
leader to do something unpopular in the
second leaders country all else being
equal a leader wants to please his
population gaining votes or more likely
avoiding revolution so if the policy
were popular he wouldn't need convincing
he would just enact it a good deal is
one that makes up for the votes lost and
the public anger created by the change
in policy your entire population may
oppose going to war but if the offer is
sweet enough you will anyway this is
also why Aid tends to flow from
democracies to dictatorships and not the
other way around a democratic politician
depends on public opinion for
re-election so he needs a lot of money
to overcome any damage to it more money
than most will pay but he does want to
buy policies to help him get reelected
of course all on someone else's dime
because public opinion is mostly
irrelevant to a dictator it can be
easily outweighed with money so
dictators make deals left and right
Democratic politicians want to buy
policies to please the people and
dictators sell them because the people
don't matter
most people think their government gives
too much aid but it doesn't matter
because they vote for policies that it
can buy
[Music]
as we've seen every leader lies
somewhere on a spectrum of how dependent
he is on the population a rich leader
doesn't need to negotiate with the
people because he doesn't need their
taxes he can sail the seas on a luxury
yacht free from the demands of his
citizens a good country is one where the
government needs your taxes and votes
and therefore must obey some of your
demands the biggest problem with foreign
aid is how it changes this relationship
when the leader of a struggling country
is suddenly handed billions of dollars
in aid his attitude can afford to change
the average citizen has a lot less
leverage with his government when it no
longer needs his taxes the more Aid is
given the more free a leader is to do
what he wishes I'm sure I don't have to
tell you what that looks like the goal
of the aid may be developing an economy
or solving a humanitarian crisis but a
smart leader knows how to milk this fact
for profit a country with a healthy
economy that's fully prepared for
disaster is one no longer in need of
help dictators are motivated to keep the
money flowing meaning maintaining if not
creating problems big enough to
necessitate aid it's not that poor
countries can't learn how to store food
or build disaster-proof homes but that
politicians have no reason to teach them
a smart leader can't earn predictable
weather patterns into a global
catastrophe if it gets more money it's
an endless cycle where Aid intensifies
disaster which creates aid and so on
[Music]
don't let all of this give you the wrong
idea a lot of aid does reach citizens
otherwise charities would stop giving it
it often comes in the form of contracts
and economic development the kind of
thing dictators can't steal but even if
one hundred percent ends up in the hands
of citizens it can still harm them
dictators must provide some minimum
conditions to avoid revolution but
giving anymore is unnecessary
so when aid reached the citizens it
isn't added to what they normally
receive it replaces it it allows
dictators to move the money they
previously spent on citizens into their
own wallets this money buys more power
keeping them on the throne longer and
decreasing dependence on the population
on top of all this corrupt states often
apply fees and taxes to incoming
donations even money earmarked for
specific things tends to magically
disappear and suddenly a new
presidential palace is built
foreign aid is not only ineffective but
actually counterproductive to fixing
problems but the alternative is to not
give aid at all even though behind these
iron dictatorships are blameless
citizens one solution may be still
giving aid but more strategically
instead of giving money up front it can
be given conditionally over time money
continues to arrive only as the quality
of life for citizens improves by giving
enough aid to entice the dictator but
only in a steady flow which stops of his
behavior changes the goal of the aid is
either achieved or not and the money
never sent some leaders won't cooperate
but their money will simply be withheld
better to not give any help at all then
give what will ultimately hurt an
innocent population but this strategy
only works if Democratic politicians use
it and why give up power to help those
that don't vote in your elections well
[Music]